this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
and that done nine months later you got
a joey diaz look-alike [__] ugly
monkey looking baby and [__] like that
so
i got irish i got irish italian jizz i'm
done i'm lucky that last i got that last
one that made it up the [__] tube
just staggered into her [__] egg and
fell into it
so i'm done my jizz is done
no i'm very lucky i'm happy and i
remember going to the doctor
my friends out in l.a the [__] the
muscle crew was like joey you're over 50
you got to take testosterone
and i started taking it i started going
to a doctor and getting a shot every
week and i ended up in the [__]
hospital giving them a gallon of blood
because
my red blood count had taken over some
[__] and i told my acupuncturist and she
told me right out she goes listen
don't do it
it don't work for cuban people and i'm
like what are you talking about she's
jewish what are you talking about
it works for everybody she goes don't do
it and sure enough
after i came out of the hospital i went
back to the [__] doctor and i told
him what had happened he's like jesus
christ this only happened one other time
to me with a cuban dude about 20 years
ago
so much
i don't know so my acupuncturist was
right she was like you don't need it you
you don't need to make testosterone you
knocked your wife up at 50.
that's your [__] testosterone what do
you need to make testosterone get a shot
for i'm like my friends are telling me
that i'll be a lot better off
nothing i'm better off now i take a
little testosterone pill twice a day i
lift weights
you do your little protein drink at
night before you [__] hit the crib
with my potassium pills
and i'm done with magnesium that's what
i've been living off of magnesium and
probiotics
that's what all my friends do do you get
stem cells and testosterone go get this
checked no i don't want no [__]
needles
i'm [__] old-schooling it i'm
original superman i'm going to the gym
i'll take a protein shake i'll eat a
banana i'll cut down on the carbs and
i'll walk
i'm going to [__] i ain't doing any
of that [__] i ain't growing my hair
back i'm not getting [__] plugs
i'm done i shaved my head at 32 i was
like i'm out
i'm out
good for you
how's the comedy going what are you
thinking so far
i don't know dude it's a weird listen
you know you know we've been
it's hard to get these engines back up
you know i i did it for 28 years
non-stop pretty much every friday and
saturday night
pretty much every night of the week
except for maybe sundays but even
sundays for most of that 28 years
and then to shut it down
for a year
and be home on fridays and saturdays
and to kind of get used to that [__]
because now i got a life
back in the day i had no life it was
just me
in some shitty apartment in new york
city
now i got this backyard i got my kid who
i [__] love he's got baseball i got
my wife we have dinner we barbecue
you know all this [__] so
now to get up at four in the morning get
in the car
go to the airport check in get on a
[__] plane go to the [__] thing
open that up you know what i mean
get get to the hotel all that [__] it's
it's like [__] man getting those engines
up and then getting to the club doing
the show two shows
[__] kill me
whose shows kill me dude you gotta work
yourself up to that now you gotta do
like a show and a guest set for like a
month
a show and then do a guest set on the
second show i you know bob it's tried
and it just wasn't working for me i
tried for about six or seven weeks
i took uh i took off from march 2nd like
everybody else till august
i got on stage with our man rich voss
and florentine at the east hanover mall
where you just performed that
i felt good that night the only thing i
was scared of that a bear was going to
come and drag me out from the [__]
thing into the woods
that's the only fear i had i did good
and then i started doing spots on uncle
vinnie's great club i loved dino
but i just wasn't feeling it i wasn't
feeling it i couldn't write new material
and i hate doing [__] old jokes
you know so i said you know what dino
let me pull the plug let me get my heart
and my soul and my head connected
and i'll come back when i'm [__]
ready you know and i'm going to feel you
dude i feel you yeah it's the new
it's the new like back in the day back a
couple of years ago
i would something would happen this
would go down i'd hold it i'd wait till
the weekday i go to the cellar i'd work
at work and work it
and then by the end of the week i'd have
a new bit
and i'd be good to go
and it was like that thing was flowing
now
i'm trying to come up with [__] but it's
not there's something missing like i
like i lost something like i can't
i don't know what the [__] it is but
even on stage i'm like yeah and i'll
start bringing something up and it'll
just go it's like just dies
and i wind up having to go back to a bit
that i know works and then your comic
guilt sets in where you're like [__] man
and then you see these young bucks
coming up behind you that are just you
know hungry little
[__] lions that are right you know
and
you know i i i think i got to push
through it i think
i think what i'm going to do is try to
get a night where i can go down like
aries is doing iris uh shafir is doing
it
well he's got a night at the stand where
it's like look this is gonna suck
so [__] you i'm just gonna do new stuff
and everybody else is coming up is
[__] off and this isn't a this is
just gonna
suck until it doesn't suck
you know what i mean because something
went out like the pilot light went out
with the new stuff and it's it's it's
killing me because you go on the road
and you feel like [__] because you know
you know when you look out and that guy
knows that you i heard that joke before
you know what i mean you're like [__]
it's it's hard and now very hard it's
true because everybody's doing the the
[__] covet [__] too so
we got to get out of that era
you know
and the whole world changed too don't
forget that there's certain things you
you know
in your head whether look i don't give a
[__] i don't got a b plan i'm going to
do what i want say what i want and if i
think it's funny i'm gonna do it but in
the back of your head that is there like
what the [__]
you know
they can't they can't listen uh
unless you got a tv show
or
they can't take nothing from you
they can take your sponsors from you and
the tv [__] show they can't take what
you do with the time you've put in and
they can't take the microphone from you
and if you're selling tickets these club
owners they'll either scab off an
iranian's head you know that they'll
[__] book you they don't give a [__]
as long as you pack the [__] room
and go up there and give them 150 you'll
always be a great comic and always have
work
people got to get this canceled culture
out of their [__] minds
you know what i'm going straight ahead
whether you cancel me or not i don't
give a [__] right i kid not you right
and put them in the [__] trunk of a
car you think i'm worried about
cancelled punch [__] you could suck my
[__] dick now at this age
i've done it all you want to come at me
now
because 23 years ago some girl sucked my
dick at the comedy store who i'm dear
friends with again now you want to come
at me over something like that and try
to cancel this and go [__] yourself
you know you got no you the reason why
cancer life exists because people let
themselves get canceled i'll [__] go
out there you see what happened in
israel
and [__] palestine they're out there
throwing rocks that's me on the stage
i'll be out there throwing [__] rocks
you text you it's like and it's
hysterical but like you text the
craziest [__] he texts that he checks
food every time you go back to jersey
you text me like pieces of pizza or the
egg roll at chan's like you you text
some crazy [__] i text big shits to you
segura and bert christian segura got the
biggest kick out of him
you can't text the [__] picture on
twitter because then you'll get 22 000
back
for weeks every time you open up a
twitter you think like it's happy
birthday it's a big piece of [__] with
[__] all over the toilet you can't do it
on the instagram or anything like that
no you can't do each other i would send
them to
[__] tom and tom would actually look
at it enlarge it oh and go what the [__]
it's it's 22 inches what did you eat you
know tom would it would really mess with
toms and sides like what why would you
send me this now i got to take a [__] to
match it you know what what am i going
to do i mean it was just
people have no idea
the
the craziness that was going on then we
after lee's apartment
we moved into an office
in like a horrible part of town oh yeah
didn't you hit somebody with your like
car door at the 7-eleven
car
that 7-11 was guys it was [__] real
there was a 7-eleven on magnolia and
whatever over lankershim past language
him past life what was our street not
constantly kawanga maybe kawenga it was
kawenga and
there was a 7-eleven there that you know
had his moments
from time to time a hindu got hit you
know a homeless guy would throw a bottle
of [__] milk at him or something
then you had the low you had the laurel
canyon 7-eleven which was [__] isis
every time you went in there they had
the turbines on they really did music on
after eight minutes you'd be [__]
saying jihad because they they would
play the music out loud like you would
be in there going next thing you know
you're dancing jihad he had [__] america
and then they killed the owner yeah they
killed the [__] no no the isis people
right in front they stabbed them to
death right in front of the laundromat
not ah people you got to be in on this
[__] to believe it but then there was
another 7-eleven on burbank
and some street it was in burbank we
rented an office there yeah that's
burbank
bank and coin it was a dump
the office was a dump oh yeah had no
windows no ac no ac the table and we had
a an african-american accountant next to
us so a consultant not even that it was
a what do you get a notary a traveling
notary notary republic
she [__] hated us from day one of us
from day one we were and we like made
there was no window so we couldn't smoke
weed in there and we didn't we never
smoked no no we smoked a vapor pipe that
you can't smell
and we have felipe in there one day and
next thing you know she's banging on the
[__] wall if you listen to the felipe
episode
she's banging on the wall we're [__]
ignoring her we're laughing their asses
off
then we were in there and there was an
earthquake with rick ramos oh jesus i
forgot about that the earthquake were
rick ramos when we were in there and we
just stopped that was a tremendous
podcast moment we had my god my uncle in
there
yeah we did do with jerry roach yeah
and then we took over
then we found then we were gonna move
out to like [__] the barbecue place
all the way out there in north hollywood
and right that was just a dump the guy's
like i walked in there i was there three
minutes and i'm drenched with sweat
and i go what's up with the air
conditioner the guy goes it's on
i got you [__] crazy what is it at
and he goes 78 what normal people put it
on i'm not in my house no my shit's at
52. this penguin's [__] running
around the house the vent the whole
[__] thing but then i did a podcast
for dre great dre great
great drake oh but you're forgetting an
office which one you're forgetting the
one on next to the in and out where the
homeless guy was in the hallway sleeping
and that
that was a very good office a little
creepy we're about to get killed yeah
because when you left there it was
[__] scary it was just dark
but that was a fun one because we would
do the periscope on the stairs yep we
would put away two [__] joints oh
and but yeah
and there was like an uh an acting
school downstairs there was a lot of
weird [__] in that office but they
didn't mess with us there was actually
we found out a weed delivery company
also in that in that building right at
the end that that was right before we
were going to move but that office
that's where we had angel salazar
that's where we had stephen bauer and we
had uh
dennis hoff dennis hoff with his
assistant [__] the rapist with the
harmonica
when he kept playing the [__]
harmonic and you would freak out
and then uh i don't know what made this
move there from there
uh
didn't the other one become available or
something right
over the holidays like january i
i had mercy and i took it to the park
and my wife was like bring it back in an
hour and i'm like what the [__] we gonna
do back in the house in an hour
so i kept her in the park all [__]
morning i went to 7-eleven i got his hot
dogs and [__]
and i got her an ice cream and as we
were walking back
the guy came out and he goes hey you're
still interested in office
we have one available on the second
floor and i was [__] blown away
you know he goes it's gonna take a week
because we got to get the caskets out of
there i go what [__] caskets because
across the street was a funeral paul and
they were using it
as a casket place i didn't know that
jesus christ i didn't know the caskets
were being stored in there yeah there
were caskets in there what are you
[__] nuts and that was
the final office we were in there for
four years and it was
just tremendous that office was uh
i still remember breaking the walls down
how painful it was you know it was it
was kind of
not bueno but
you know lee
we did the eight years you got the
[__] uh lisa yet not a space
which hopefully someday you'll turn into
an nft are you just going back oh that's
coming and uh
it was just really weird how did you
feel when i came to you that day and
said
because it was about a year ago
it was about a year ago
that i said you know
i think it's time for us to end this how
did you feel at first
well
i wouldn't have stayed in la
nearly as long as i did if it wasn't for
the podcast i didn't like i missed some
people in la and i missed the weather
right now but el i didn't i never liked
la
um
there's always going to be a little bit
of sadness um but it wasn't
it wasn't really out of the blue you'd
been talking about leaving
for like three or four years it felt
like at least like no no like nailed
down time
but
you know i owe it wherever you because i
i've said this for months and people ask
i honestly feel like our relationship is
better now yes um i feel like
it it's good
because i mean you've seen tv shows
podcasts anything
go on for too long
and that wouldn't
like that would hurt
um
i had a great time doing it
i i i miss you
but
it it it is kind of weird i'm not i'm
not a very religious person but if you
look at it we started the podcast the
first week of september 2012 and ended
the last week of august
of 2020. there isn't any other place
that david
would know to talk about in such a
poetic and incredible way
i gotta tell you i'm very proud of being
from new jersey
but this movie pushed it over the top
for me
yeah i have to really be on this was my
stripes
this is my biker jacket
you know this is my
uh it's funny he said i was again my
wife was watching it she's been watching
now for about two and a half months
so i try to play the guitar while she's
watching it and [__] because i've
already seen the episodes back and forth
but sometimes i'll come in and she's
watching the last episode a couple weeks
ago she was watching the episode when
carmella had to visit the guy in uh
college at columbia
he took her out to lunch to try to
uh
to try to get the 50 grand from her and
she goes i didn't know you were from
jersey i didn't know you were italian he
goes yeah ross
short for rosetti you know
and he goes uh something about the
jersey school system i've always been
[__] proud about the jersey school
systems i think i learned
you know i [__] a savage from the
jersey school system because i didn't
just teach you about school they taught
you how to get over how to get free milk
they don't [__] around new jersey they
had a driver red teacher
that he we used to talk him into
stopping and getting chinese food that's
part of the [__] education we used to
yeah of course we used to [__] sign
up at a quarter to 11 to make sure he
would have the car you know we would be
with him till 11 30. and we would talk
him into come on mr mcgrath you got to
stop a chance yeah a couple steaks on
the stick come on we know you're hungry
we get the steak on the stick and make
sure he'd eat one first so then we
you're guilty you know what i'm saying
now you can't rat us out we're all good
but there's something about
being from jersey like i told my when i
got here last september i took my
daughter around the corner and right
away i remembered kids in new jersey you
ready for this
most kids go out to play in new jersey
you won't have to die
like
like when i was a kid in new jersey i
used to give my mother a hug and tell
like i left a will i left a little note
under the pillow it would have been my
trains and my hot wheels because i'm
going to die yeah we were kids in new
jersey you didn't go out to play [__]
whatever you went out to die like god
forbid some car pulled up to you when
you were playing stickball and wanted
you to move you know how many [__]
fights we got into as kids with people
driving cars because who the [__] are
you to drive down the street right now
it's two outs we got the bases are
[__] loaded we got the puerto rican
up at bat and you want to [__] drive
here now get the [__] out of here come
back in 20 minutes go [__] yourself and
we [__] jump the guy and next thing
you know so
there's something about jersey there's
something about being from brooklyn yeah
there's something about being from the
bronx there's something about being from
harlem but there is something
from being from jersey now you went to
high school in studio city correct
yeah so i you know i grew up in in um so
my whole family lives in bergen county
and then i grew up in manhattan and
jersey going back and forth my whole
life
and then we moved out to la um in uh
in middle school so i was in middle
school and we moved out and i did middle
school and high school in la
and then i turned 18 and went back to
new york for for college and uh
and now i've been back ever since you
know i'm an east coast boy um i i
[__] love it here and yeah i do agree
like i think that
after doing this movie there is a
certain odd pride about jersey that i
have now that i never had before um
just a real a real love for it so yeah
like i said as i was shooting the movie
then my days off i would take the ferry
over
and
i got reacquainted yeah i got
reacquainted i took a couple rides with
my friends bergen county
and i said what the [__]
am i doing out there
and
it was just a process of when can we
make the move back yeah what a lot of
people didn't know is we were supposed
to come back and shoot
well you had started shooting already on
the 9th of march
well i did it yeah i was the last day
before we got shut down which is that i
it was the phone booth scene um
that was the scene before we got shut
down when we were really reshoots yeah
yeah
yeah that was the the scene and
um then we got shut down and
we
kind of were all just waiting you know
for [__] forever um and september
came around and we we did those reshoots
those last couple scenes
did you did you ever get to shoot in
jersey
nope
yeah i know we me and david you know we
i know david really wanted to shoot more
in jersey
i got to shoot
i believe
two days in jersey and i remember
it just felt different there was like
something really special about it
beginning to like
i was just so happy we got to shoot a
couple things in in new jersey it just
felt really right you know what i mean
it was awesome
when i got the movie i was very excited
about hanging out in newark yeah i was
like [__] we're gonna shoot newark yeah
i haven't been to newark in months
they've got the spanish kitchen they
have a great portuguese section they got
great italian food they got a couple
cuban restaurants
we'll go out at night in newark you know
and then when we got here i didn't have
newark at all anywhere in my shoot dates
and it didn't depress me i didn't i was
just listen
i was just happy to be a part of it for
me
michael i was just happy to be a part of
it i knew it was going to be something
big
yeah i knew it was going to be something
special
when i heard you were in it i really
wanted to be in it and uh you know i
didn't know i knew john
yeah you know but i didn't know like
sam i didn't know
little paulie corey i didn't know a lot
of those guys [__] samson i love that
[__] all of them all of them you
know
uh ray liotta was great to shoot with
him he was [__] dynamite you know
and i gotta tell
for people who don't know he's another
guy that did great in this [__] movie
i think his character was [__]
tremendous i think david hit it out of
the park with his character yeah
everyone everyone i'm just so proud of
everyone they're just everyone's so
so good in it and like
to have such a blast i mean
for not not one of us [__] hated
anyone like do you know how rare that is
like not one there's gotta be one guy
that like i can't stand that person like
it wasn't anyone like it was just the
best
how did so how did you
did you audition or did you just get it
offered how did it come your way
i found out he was doing it
i thought about it for like a week
and i contacted john
john i don't have the script nobody
knows you know i knew dave wasn't gonna
have a script out there
i knew david wasn't gonna have the right
lines out there i knew david was not
gonna
give you lines from the movie at all or
anything
so i just i thought about it and i
talked to my agent
and they sent the
sides you know and i looked at the sides
and there was a trick question
in the sides what was it it was a trick
it was it was a
it was a uh
just the way he did the line yeah i was
supposed to react to it a certain way ah
okay okay and at first i looked at it i
didn't know what to do
but voila
yeah i thought about a scene with silvio
and your dad god rest his soul
and i go
that's the scene
he's referring to i'm gonna do this
nice and so it was fascinating for me to
watch you guys
do the same thing i was doing but have
such a different journey like the
audience's reactions to you guys
especially when they didn't get you
was something i never had to do
you know
yeah especially when you were this joe
diaz when you were this guy oh [__] this
dude
this dude
the hand pumper you made some people
nervous a front foot jack when you were
doing
pissed it
god damn
do you
do you remember the very first time
you know the very first time i saw brody
snap on stage
was at the underground and his jokes
were he was bomb
just and
he he said i don't think you understand
people how hard it is for a single man
to shave his own back by himself he goes
i got trouble spots and he lifted up his
shirt and he showed the patches on his
back
yo
trouble spots
i was howling but i was like in my life
i'll never have to do that
you know what i mean
it was great
yeah to watch brody
especially at the store and at the
underground
i have those memories drilled listen man
i have a problem i can't remember
nothing
from
2010 on
like if you bust my balls about 2014 i
don't know nothing
between the edibles the [__] reefer
the kid god knows nothing i destroyed my
[__] memory
but i have and i have real memories of
brody like on stage at the store
and me going i don't think bro he's
gonna last
because he was having like when he first
got to la he was going up there doing
eight minutes they weren't on board and
he would just snap and that's what made
him funny you know we loved it we loved
his comics and [__] you know in the
back
but the audience he was struggling you
know he was struggling and i respected
brody because he showed up every [__]
night he didn't give a [__]
what happened the night before he had
the right attitude
that was last night [__]
tonight's tonight okay so
it's funny that we did learn a lot from
one another i learned a lot of [__] from
do you remember doing the [__]
industrial
that saturday like in september we had a
do a an industrial shoot where we had to
just pick up boxes and drop them off for
people like just pick them up and drop
they gave us like 75 bucks it was like
ups and all me josh and gavin did was
like pick up boxes
and like every once in a while we wave
at the camera and the guy will go don't
do that
and i remember going this is my first
industrial oh my god i'm on my way like
i i still remember going out i still
remember going to l.a
my first audition was judy brown
called me up she was booking the jenny
mccarthy show
which for you people don't know judy
brown is one of the biggest managers in
the world today sebastian
whitney [__] uh
bill what's his name not bill bird but
bert kreischer i'm really proud of judy
judy came a long way i met judy in
colorado springs when she was charging
20 bucks to take a stand-up class before
you could do the open mic there and [__]
i'm like julian yeah i'm not paying you
20 bucks
she's every time i see it she's like you
never paid me that
i'm not gonna pay you that 20. in fact
you owe me 35 hours from [__] vail
how's that when my car blew up and i
left it there and i had to call the
dealer and go remember that nice [__]
car that was there yet the engine blew
where are you i'm in the [__] i'm in
vail i'm i quit
i'm in a manny's car dawg i [__]
climb with that matey's car i was
talking about the ant-many car the other
day when they got towed and i tried to
go down to hollywood to get my [__] out
of it and they're like you need a
registration and i actually went home
and like
got carol's registration and tried the
[__]
i thought how many tickets were on that
car
200.
that's not an exaggeration by the way i
remember seeing those tickets in the
back seat you should just take them and
throw them in
i just took them and threw them in the
back and [__]
i still remember the lady would follow
me the little black lady with the she
had like a [__] cheese danish on her
head
she spun it around the head like the
afro she was the most angriest woman in
the world i brought her flowers i sang a
michael jackson songs i would sing al
green songs i threw the whole black
catalog of love music at this sister
cause she was fine too
yeah and she would get out of my face
and i remember finally one day she goes
i'm just gonna keep giving you tickets
and i go
[__] it i had a stack and a
there must have been a hundred in there
she goes oh lord
you gonna go to jail
and they didn't tell me in hollywood it
doesn't matter they got me up in [__]
the valley
yeah they got me in the valley with that
[__] car i was in there taking a
shower i go outside to get my shorts the
car is gone i didn't bring all my
luggage with me i just took a t-shirt if
i would have brought my whole luggage
with me i wouldn't have been in this
predicament today
let me tell you
the when i used to get in i remember
getting that car and looking in the back
seat and being like
you got some tickets and you're like
yeah i'm like
are you gonna pay them you're like nah
they're gonna have to come get me and
that was it
what am i gonna pay him what what what
do you want my good looks the car had no
brakes no
no brakes i would have to step on the f
i was like fred flintstone for real i'd
have my foot on the brake and the other
foot outside the door stopping the
[__] car i stopped dog on the 405
south i had to do it one time
the car had a tremendous cassette player
a sunroof and air conditioning
you don't know how many times i would
just park on the street
pop the seat back boom and just pop the
sunroof i still remember being on vista
and jerking off doing coke in the car
[__] jerking off and then taking
napkins and and putting them outside and
i remember waking up in the morning when
the sun wakes you up and stretching and
looking down and seeing like eight
little sperm napkins and going this is
not good this is not good
i jerked off on the street i'm visiting
i'm going out
i would not be surprised if those sperm
napkins were still on that street right
where you left them
drive right down the block there's
probably a homeless guy wiping his face
he's just eating a subway sandwich and
he's taking my little sperm napkin and
wiping his sides like gray poupon and
[__]
yo do you remember
when that dude oh by the way
jacob wolf was at that travis scott
concert on friday
yo i forgot to tell you this
so i'm so glad i was asleep but i wake
up to a text
hey i'm all right
but [__] got real hairy
so
he and his girlfriend
have bruises
circling their body from where they were
being smushed by the crowd he showed me
my man just has bruises because he was
being compressed
oh joe i forgot this story is so bananas
man
he said at one point his girlfriend
who's smaller
her feet weren't touching the ground
but she was stuck between people and
just being moved
there was she was like this
and so many people compressed she was
being moved by the crowd i am so happy
to see you i
you know i asked around i didn't know
what was going on
i talked to some of the boys from the
sports advisors from time to time they
come to the shows
i didn't even know you were in the
business at all anymore
wow i moved to new york i put on i see
you on twitter i follow you and you're
[__] great i've been following you
retweeting the games for the week
you are a [__]
professional man
ah everything's good you know it's all
i've ever done so in other words uh and
now with the internet and now with a new
audience of young people you know i'm
just as [__] crazy as ever i mean the
energy is ever you know uh is is bigger
than ever i take a tear shot every two
weeks and uh that just gives me
unlimited [__] energy you know live
on caffeine right now caffeine and a tee
shot and uh i'm ready to go i mean i'm
only sleeping like four hours a night
and loving life you know i got you know
i got four uh men that live with me my
kids 32 30 26 22. and three of the four
live with me and total insanity
everybody's partying every day drinking
every day you know getting [__] up and
uh you know it's a great life you've
worked some great [__] life you know
broken 50 blunts a day nine cups of
starbucks coffee
how the [__] do you do this i'm cuban
i was doing eight shots of espresso in
l.a nice flavor at night four before i
went to the comedy store oh i love it
and i love it here and i stopped
drinking espresso like i just drink one
cup of coffee now
and and that does it for you huh that
does it throughout the day i gotta drink
a coke zero for caffeine purposes right
a headache away
but beside that man you look great
i love that you put pictures of your dad
he's your [__] twin
so what has happened in 30 years
um well i mean basically you know i went
uh almost broke three times and uh now i
got the world by the balls i'm printing
money i got i got [__] in my backyard
i got five [__] trees hundred dollar
bills on the trees when you come here
when we get [__] up i'm gonna let you
pick hundred dollar bills you leave with
five ten grand everybody's happy ready
to roll oh my god
you are insane i mean everything
every day is insane you know even even
with the culvert we got you know
anywhere between 10 to 40 people a day
running around my backyard um the house
that i've been living in since 1990
that's still what i have uh i work i
worked as a landscaper when i was a kid
in seventh grade joe and um on a 7.8
acre estate it was the william
schwindler estate and he was the
co-founder of grumman aerospace with
leroy grumman and in uh world war ii in
the 40s vice presidents used to be in my
basement because they were talking about
you know how the [__] they could bomb
germany and [__] bomb japan and win
the [__] war god god willing um
william schwindler's claim to fame was
the movie apollo 13 uh with tom hanks
and gary sinise well in that movie
there's a scene where they have two
tables and they throw all the [__] on
the tables and they said to the
scientists we got to get them down and
the owner of this house william
schwindler got them down and that was
his claim to thing they landed at
laguardia airport drove right to
hicksville where grumman aerospace is
and i'm about two minutes away from
there so it was a
acre estate and oddly enough in seventh
grade i said um mr schwindler mrs
schwindler
when you sell this house i would like to
buy it and they looked at me with like
two heads they're like what's this
[__] jew talking about hey buddy you
know go wipe your butt you say you're
you're [__] 14 by the grace of god
you know i scored out in the 80s uh with
my sports advisor service and with 900
numbers and when they died it was in the
will for them to call me they called me
in 1989 they wanted at the time 2.2
million negotiated for six months and i
paid 1.4 million the 7.8 acres it's a uh
a 1.8 acre side field uh 2.5 acres with
the house is on and then 3.2 acres in
the back the house at the time was 1900
square feet
1936 english tudor and then when i
bought it i put 800 grand into the house
200 000 into the pool made it 4 300
square feet matched the brick and the
slate roof from a burnt down school in
massachusetts and i've been kicking
[__] ass since in 1994 i paid um 4.8
million dollars for a score phone
operation in atlanta georgia where um
they were getting 48 million calls a
year on 200 score phones and at the time
before the internet before you could get
scores on your phone before all these
channels on tv gave scores we gave
scores odds lines injury weather reports
and then we inundated it with ads um i
sold the back field in my backyard to a
builder together we built 11 houses and
we named it after my oldest son it's
called shawn michael court um i sold a
1.8 acre side field right next to me and
then i kept the 2.5 acres bought the
score phone um paid 4.8 million put 800
000 down had a note for 1.2 million per
year we wrote 10
million in four years or by the bulls
business was evaluated at 30 million ps
this is nuts joe you this is [__]
crazy it's like murphy's law my last
payment
to the owner
paid it
me and sandy go to france party our
[__] balls off come back
and cbs sportsline opened their website
i went in six months 48 million calls
4.8 million calls 480 000 calls 48 000
calls
at a [__] business
and then i had to get into other areas
so i got like professional athletes uh
to work for me ex-coaches ex-players and
i promoted them
and then that didn't work and then it
almost put me out of business and i
floundered probably from 1999
2000 to 2010 on the balls of my ass i
couldn't afford water for my kids and i
just grinded grinded i beg barred and
stealed borrowed money from everybody i
ever [__] met or money from the mafia
didn't pay my taxes i dug a seven
million dollar hole because
i didn't want to lose my life and my
lifestyle i was advised go out of
business bankrupt yourself wipe it out
and start again i'm like well a can't
beat the monkey out of money because
don't put a gun in my head my my mouth
and kill me b
government ain't going away and see i
can't [__] friends my sister-in-law lent
me money every friend i ever met p.s
by 2018
i paid every [__] penny back seven
million [__] dollars and then by the
grace of god dave portnoy who owns bar
stool sports called me and said stu
me and my father used to watch you in
the 90s on the sports advisors we
[__] love you we don't like you we
love you we want to bring back your
sports advisors show re-branded barstool
sports devices and then um in 2006 they
used my tv show in the movie two for the
money al pacino played me rene russo
played my wife matthew mcconaughey in
real life played a disgruntled employee
that worked for me and in that movie al
pacino
yeah exactly al pacino matthew
mcconaughey and jeremy pippen were on my
tv show so basically now i'm like the
hottest [__] thing in the world i
mean i'm not as hot as you i'm not as
good looking as you but i'm [__] hot
as [__] just like you said the other day
you go to a carville your mom i can't go
anywhere without people and by the grace
of god listen if i was [__] my wife
and someone wanted to take a picture i
would tell my wife honey hold on and
i'll take the picture because this is
like this is like living a a storybook
life i mean um
one of my favorite scenes
uh is the
scene where i console
or i i wouldn't say console but it's
probably the only time
in retrospect
that you see herc
be kind
is with bodhi's grandmother
when they raid and they're turning oh
yes yes yes sir
real early in the show yeah you go and
yeah what the [__] were you doing in
there right you were very gentle and you
know what i remember getting shaken down
by cops in time and there was one cop
that came back and he was like
we're sorry about this you know not
nothing personal
but the show is very unapologetic
as you watch this show you're gonna
realize
um
people don't change
people are who they are you know you
watch a show and a lot of people sort of
have this epiphany
and they change their life and
all
their bad
qualities are
miraculously gone
doesn't happen in this world
does not happen
i played a character for five years who
more or less was a bully
when he needed to be
who worked outside of the lines
yes he tried he was doing it to bring
down drug dealers
you know it's not like he was doing it
to to rob old ladies or whatever but it
doesn't justify what he was doing
he wasn't able to work within the
guidelines in order to make a case or
bring up a wire
but
if you notice and that we could we could
have this conversation when you finish
the show
because
you're gonna say oh
you know
hurricane carver that [__] ups did this
that that but
i have a rebuttal for that sometimes
because i've heard it enough time
but um
there's no
hope
in the shell
anybody
who represents hope
doesn't make it
and you see that
you're on season three you're with
hamster damn bonnie colvin has been
introduced i think it's just robert f
wisdom
who you should definitely have
on your pod because i mean
even his history rasafarian and
and bob marley i mean man i don't even
want to give it away but
um i i would i would love to facilitate
that for you because you should have
them on your show i love keema and i'll
help you out anyway
i love keema
keema i love kemah
i like what she's going through right
now with the with the [__] wife and
the she's pregnant and she don't want to
be a cop and then on the other end you
got the smooth
chief the the the the thin brother
that could pass
and he's going through the same thing
with his wife and my head i'm watching
this going i've never seen a show where
they're showing you what's going on at
home
now as a cop
joey do you realize this um
this show
it's
it
shows
everybody every race every class
everybody in all different stages
whether you could be white and corrupt
you could be white in the nice part you
could be on the street and have a heart
you could have a badge all the
credentials all the stripes on your
sleeves and be the
be just as bad as the person that you're
trying to incarcerate
you could be a politician you'll get to
that later
but you see it
you see the breakdown you see the
breakdown of the social fabric because
the show
is
the star of the show is baltimore
baltimore represents every little
american city in the united states
you understand yeah so
that
is why that show
resonated should have resonated back
then and it resonates even more so today
it's i'm watching it and it's like it
happened yesterday let's get that away
almost like it's timeless and and and
david
david simon
nina
uh
big shout out to ed burns robert f
colesberry all the writers all the
producers who have played on that show
and um
they're a genius
now let's get to the other side of this
because let me tell you something to
fill that void
whoever did the casting
i'll suck his dick or her dick
the casting
is wait you don't know you don't know
alexa fogle no i'm a l.a
you had to submit a tape to alexa oh my
god no
never was all all tom fantanas stuff
nothing
she is
not new york she's new york ever cast
that show when i see that chubby black
dude
with the dredge that's a drug deal like
a kingpin and his own that uh
proposition joe proposition joe the
casting on him
he passed away but got pregnant god
bless you
[__] real the acting on that dude
unreal his look
the casting when he's eaten
no you know it just shows i mean it's
the snoop coming to the pitcher
no snoop not yet
with omar
not yet snoop dogg
no the the girl snoop
no she hasn't been in yet now
we have enough
for something yeah we haven't even
gotten the [__] omar i decided early
on
with all the television i've watched
everything movies i think one of my
favorite [__] bad guys right now
hands down is omar when he comes into
the projects and he goes oh the big bad
wolf and he's like don't make me come up
there he [__] the shotgun
and it's like a six second now like
maybe 20 second pause and you're like
why isn't anybody shooting this
[__] from a window but instead a
bag of crack falls out of a [__]
window and lands next to him and you're
like holy [__]
the writing
is second to none
i like
that they didn't make the longshoremen
italian
that would have been the easy rap
yeah and that that's not the case in
baltimore and baltimore right it's not
the case they made them polish and
whatever uh greek
you know i like all
dog and even that guy not the guy the
guy that played the greek
has been in a thousand things
who the old man the old man which guy
are you talking about the glasses that
they want to see him all the time
uh the longshoremen want to keep seeing
him and finally he shows up an old guy
he was on miami talking about paul
victor or bill raymond
then there's a little guy that he was in
casino oh no he was in uh
the irishman
he was in the irishman the dude there's
two dudes that play the greek the one
dude is the one that talks
my boy everybody loves raymond and
pacino to invest in his hotel in vegas
come on what can we do here for us
the guy that you uh
you see you remember
he played in the the three stooges as
well
i thought that's where you were going no
no no no i'm a three stooges
[Applause]
i love all that [__] we're trying to
make it happen people want to bother me
when i'm starting
this beautiful [__] episode of the
joint
i'm feeling good i'm feeling better
i just smoked a little before the
podcast to loosen up a little bit get
the speedy those milos out of here i
didn't know if i told you yet we're back
monday but i'm also back mentally on the
[__] if you ain't high by two o'clock
go [__] your mother it's back in full
[__] swing
i've been doing it for 30 days now so
that puts me back in the club and back
as the ceo
if you don't if you're not high by two
o'clock i don't know what to do with
yourself you know i'm saying me i'm
happy again because i get to smoke a
little roots and walk on the [__]
treadmill speaking of the treadmill i
was on that [__] this morning
doing my little joint
listening to power rage again i've been
going through every day i put in a
different album like yesterday was
[__] pyromania the day before
saturday was high and dry
[__] friday was no friday i didn't
walk yes i did i walked at night i put a
little black sabbath greatest hits i'm
always mixing it [__] up on the
treadmill but listen like i told you
[__] the treadmill got a lot
easier
when i do three [__] bong hits
i don't even put visine in my eyes i go
out there wrong dog in it you know what
i'm saying it's in the it's early in the
morning i ain't gonna bump into no
parents i ain't gonna bump into normally
i'm gonna bump into the [__] relics
at the gym and they know i like to
[__] smoke some reef from time to
time
but besides that it's been a great
[__] week so far before the
podcast started my shoulder popped out
so if i make funny faces like i got to
take a [__] it's got nothing to do with
that my [__] shoulder popped out me
and mike outside hitting the the [__]
blunt of death he had one of his [__]
cocoa blunts
and i had a regular blunt from the dudes
and
we took a couple hits nice
nice it's gonna snow
it was supposed to snow yesterday it
came down for a [__] maybe eight
[__] minutes i was excited too i'm
like [__] some snow people gonna be
off the streets my daughter's at school
that means when she gets home at [__]
four or three we gotta have a little
snowball fight kaputz and turn into
[__] water i don't know about this
climate [__] all i know is that when i
was growing up in jersey you didn't see
the sidewalk from [__] december to
like march and then you started seeing
like yellow snow the first snow
that the dogs pissed on you see those
little frozen shits and then you see
like 22 inches of snow on top of that
that's the [__] jersey i grew up in
people calling me every day joey how
cold is it i mean it's 37
it was 15 last week that was cold but
besides that guys i grew up in this
[__] state when january was zero
zero like i've been thinking oh my god i
was thinking about my [__] past
january's here like it
like i did three things but i still
remember
the cold [__] weather like i could
still remember
pretty much what i wore to combat the
weather like the coldest night i think i
ever
encountered as a young kid i had a lot
of cold nights
but in january like i remember when
i had to cut through a cemetery one
night and it was freezing i had to pee
and my pee froze and my pants because i
took a [__] and i peed but i didn't pull
my pants all the way down and the pea
froze in my pants and then i remember
another night
when we were up at hudson county park
that was one of the coldest nights i
ever [__] encountered i had a stop
like every two blocks to duck in to get
warm people were throwing this out i
wasn't even giving a [__] i was just
going into business with my buddy luke's
we're like [__] it that's the night we
went to
the wing fund on 78th and bergen line
that was one of the last times i ran out
of that [__] because we would go
in there and rob from them like not rob
physically but we go in there and get
like three entrees soups and [__] and
then we'd run the [__] out of there we
must have done that 20 times i think by
80 81 they got used to us so now they
would [__]
lock the doors and [__] and it was just
bori i got bored with them chasing me
but one night we were in there
and then there was another night tonight
i went to see missing persons
in passaic
there's a [__] pretty good venue in
passaic i only went to passaic two times
to start theater early on before i knew
who the [__] they were
i went to see rainbow
and the [__] scorpions
and i knew michael shankly was there
i went with this [__] dude that was a
big he was into that type of music and
he had the ticket
but
the night i went there with fernie
basically my man beniri
we froze to death and we had a [__]
car he had a car and we were freezing
with the heater on that's how [__]
cold jersey was that's what i [__]
remember about jersey and on the corners
the puddle in the daytime the sun would
melt a little bit of the [__] snow
so the quarters the corners excuse me
would just be draining
uh like little melted [__] things but
if it got like after about by lunchtime
the drain would start to fill in and you
wouldn't know it you'd be walking down
the street concentrating on staying warm
and [__] minding your own business and
you stepped off the [__] sidewalk and
your whole foot went into that because
you thought it looked like ice it was it
would freeze
every 30 seconds the [__] would
freeze
you could step on it keep going and go
[__] i can't believe i went through the
ice your foot would be you would have to
wear even the galoshes they went through
i mean i was a galache man i didn't like
winter boots and [__]
yeah i was a galache man growing up
those galoshes like 10 [__] bucks you
strap them on your shoes over your boots
and they don't let you slip if i was a
goulash man so i could tell you
those galoshes are good if you're not
going to go deep sea [__] fish diving
if your foot goes to the ice the
galactic do no good your whole [__]
foot gets wet and all sudden you're
walking home and you hear like
and after about another mile that
[__] foot freezes the [__] up dog
that's what i think that's what inspired
my fungi toenail that i got [__]
frosted all the way to the end when i
was a kid i remember those [__]
nights i just
there was a the prosaic theater
there was the night with focaracho then
there was another night i can't remember
it doesn't [__] oh it was the same
night the night i ate the quaalude with
folk and those guys i couldn't make it
home i had to sleep in a [__]
alleyway until this day i got to ask
myself how the [__] i stayed warm in
that [__] all night because when
i woke up i couldn't move parts of my
[__] body i think it was the quaalude
that stopped my what's that [__] when
your bones freeze
outside if you don't have [__]
weather if you don't have like gloves on
and you keep throwing what's it called
yeah frost bite if you have frostbite
for a few minutes the [__] finger
falls off or whatever the [__] happens
dawg i slept on this fridge and
[__] all night had igloos around
me
that was about the time
whenever i think about this dog listen
guys i was a [__] young man i
i have no regrets i
i will always tell you this because i
don't want you to think like i was a phi
beta cat but when you look at the
pictures i posted a few weeks ago my
shoulders are big and you know i look
good and stuff but i was a [__]
complete [__]
and i'll never forget like 80 81
i think i told this story on the joe
rogan podcast and people hated me for
this
i had gotten some dough that was when i
[__]
cashed the checks i cast these three
checks
i ended up making like 20 grand i was in
high school when i put the 20 grand in
my draw
under my socks and [__] nobody ever knew
that money was there
my friends would come over i was living
with the bend there's nobody and i would
just take the 20 off the top every night
like i was like my own atm machine i
don't know how long it lasted
and it's it's wild how
anything within that can sort of create
a reality whether it's a
reality that's close to what's actually
going on or us thinking our parents are
still alive
we're thinking those thoughts and we
might seem crazy to other people but
that is our reality that's our truth in
that moment because our brain isn't you
know it's it's so powerful that it
creates whatever that
world is
it really is like your your mind is
unbelievable
you know i was reading about that new
diet
oh god
no i was just reading about it some guy
was talking about on instagram
they had something and i said let me
look this thing up and it's a diet
unlike like weight watchers or whatever
it attacks your mental
wow you wanted to this diet the first 20
days or something there's a lot of
journaling
a lot of walking 9 000 steps a day [__]
like that but it teaches you how to eat
all over again
but it's psychological and it's pretty
interesting i was thinking about joining
up and seeing what it's about i'm just
not in the mood to start another [__]
diet i'm happy with
white watches if
it works but
it just goes to show you that if the
mind can
what's that the mind can conceive the
body can achieve
yes so it all starts with your mind
it really does it's like you can create
your own placebo effect it's so weird
how i did a podcast last year about
turning the switch
how
some people it's harder for
some people turn the switch on quicker
than others if i put two people
on the same open mic and watch them and
they both do the same amount of sets
every night
one guy is going to naturally be ahead
of the other guy you know i'm saying
like one
guy and then the one guy catches up over
in time the guy that got ahead his cat
dies he doesn't go off for a week and
then the other guy comes in and does the
sets and catch up to him
but it's just really interesting how
we could start at the same time and we
could both have different results but we
both get to the same destination
yeah i'm saying like we can't yes the
destination is the comedy store every
night on stage that's where i want to be
so when you write down that goal that's
where it starts i want to be at the
comedy store four nights a week next to
bill bird next to jessica may paluso
next to joe rogan and the more you write
that that's why i always say i like
writing goals because the power of the
pen the power of the pen will take you
there without you even [__] knowing
it's so weird even now i write little
goals and i go to the gym and boom three
weeks later i'm achieving them and i
thought i can you know like
being able to roll 20 minutes in a row
you know on their own machine whatever
the [__] like i always do stupid [__]
like that you know i started walking
on the treadmill so you got to like
[__] put it up to 10 and run up the
hill and die and then switch it but you
got to change it up on your mind you
know it's so weird how the mind and i
got to be honest with you
and people aren't going to believe me
when i tell you this
with comedy i did a lot of [__]
meditating and i had to see myself there
first
like i would go to a theater with joe
rogan and go
wow
i'm never going to be able to play this
[__] theater
and then i would go see you're catching
yourself talking [__]
yep you have to leave here saying you'll
be back on your own one [__] day when
you leave the theater have your hand
touch the wall or whatever then go home
that night and write it
i want to play this [__] theater when
i open when i used to work for joe and i
would go to those theaters i [__]
wrote those theater's names down and i
think
i like the 31 theaters he took me to i
went to 27 of them on my own wow
you know and i always a lot of people
don't know about that little secret that
i did on my own just to
prove to myself that this is where you
came at one time as an opener
and now you came back here as a
headliner
yeah it's it's you know you're basically
applying a lot of really
advanced
strategy for yourself you know
visualizing and visualization is huge
for achieving goals it's probably one of
the most important aspects of it and
writing it down i do the same thing i do
the same exact thing mainly because i my
i have 80d like
you know actually diagnosed add not just
when people say oh i have ocd of add i
really do and it's v it's a struggle
and one of the things that helps me with
all my chaotic thoughts is writing them
all down
and i realize the same thing where you
you start to write things down and then
you're like
it's really it's really important to
track yourself
otherwise we're just ships with no
direction we're literally just floating
around in this [__] ocean not not
doing anything not going to any port not
visiting anybody not catching any
[__] fish you're just a ship in the
ocean doing jack [__] you're rudderless
you're rudderless and and it's funny
because when i got into comedy
i knew nothing you know i didn't have a
coach to tell you so everything i did i
figured out on my own and the little
things were to write
the date
the name of the venue
you know if you were a feature or a
headliner or emcee
i wish i would have done that and i
would write out my set
and then
but i would be honest with myself like
when i get home from a show
before i even did a line of coke
before i rolled the joint before i peed
before i took a [__]
it was a discipline that i opened up
this notebook and would write down my
sets
so i did uh
the houston lap stop
i did okay
i could have done better
would you write that down yes and i
wouldn't write the reasoning like i
would never say the audience sucked
i would always put i need to work
harder and i would always put the
material that i used
the key jokes so when i come back
i don't use those jokes again
and it's funny when i lived in boulder i
started that and in boulder i had a
set 20-month
month goal you were not gonna hit it
there wasn't 20 cents
there was no way colorado yeah when i
was an open mic unless somebody took you
on the road and i wasn't ready for that
unless you're entertaining a
field of weed
yeah no i would go to like
i would follow like a [__] uh what's
that [__] that miley cyrus's dad
invented
the whoopee song whatever the [__] my
icky breaky heart remember they used to
dance that [__] dance in my breaky
breaky heart a bunch of rednecks with
boots and hats on and a [__] boss
shuffling
dog sunday nights i would follow uh line
dancing class
there was comedy at eight after a
[__] hour line dancing class
you had to throw that right
next out
because that's the way the club did it
and then they do
country dancing that night at nine
[__] horrible
you know monday i was at a [__]
australian bar and they put us in the
back in the rehearsal room like the
rooms had padding and [__] on it and you
had to close the door and you couldn't
breathe in there people were on stage
turning purple because it was like a
bank vault and they would only seat 16
people
tuesdays i had the comedy works
wednesday at club 56
or the [__] elvis in person at his
room he was a chef and then he was an
elvis impersonator he weighed like 500
pounds so i had to open for him and then
wait for him to do his set so i could go
back up there and greet him good night
nobody knows i'd rather take it up the
ass than had that job now in hindsight
that i think about it
seeing an elvis impersonator is [__]
suicide like that's what elvis like
listen i'm not you could either do 20
years in jail
or sit through a set of an elvis
impersonator with a knife next to you if
you can make it you'll [__] walk free
out of this [__] prison
thursday i had el torito
the mexican joint burbank where the
[__] you get poisoned in there the
food was horrible
cry out of your [__] el torito was so
[__] bad
[Music]
hmm
you